hey there I'm Tiffany Smith for Fandango
movie clips and I am super excited
because London has fallen is coming to
theaters and it is the follow-up no not
to White House down this is the
follow-up to Olympus has fallen in honor
of the fall of London we thought we
would put together the most cinematic
ways to destroy a city of course we've
got Mother Nature herself that's right
we're talking about a good old-fashioned
natural disaster there's nothing quite
like a volcano in a populated
metropolitan area like Los Angeles which
I gotta say is a nice change of pace
from their usual
earthquakes and speaking of earthquakes
they can prove to really shake things up
and knock them down well unless you've
got you know Dwayne Johnson just hanging
out cuz he always saves the day next up
are our friends in the animal kingdom I
gotta say you guys the way that we treat
them I feel like we're kind of asking
for it so the next time you come across
a giant ape in the wild or discover a
way to bring back an extinct species
think twice before you do something that
might really tick off a giant lizard or
a stampeding rhinoceros moving along to
at my personal favorite the ironic
superhero fight yes they're just trying
to save the city but with all those
powerful punches flying bodies and laser
blasts there's bound to be some
collateral damage a pretty hefty price
tag and don't get me started on the
traffic but I still have superheroes and
next on the list we need to look to the
stars that's right I'm talking about
aliens and not the cute candy eating
times you just want to touch your finger
and phone home I'm talking about the
face melting earth harvesting laser
blasting from their eyes
terrifying aliens why don't they attack
from the skies or in their badass
spaceship or they come through a portal
on the ocean floor they mean business
and they don't have much respect for our
people our city is for even are really
cool landmarks
all right so that brings us to its basic
human stupidity that's right our methods
maybe a little bit more subtle but at
the end of the day we are just as
capable of destroying our own cities and
planets as any cold-blooded alien
I'm Tiffany Smith for Fandango movie
clips thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]